what's going on rejects John is driving
we are on our way to go watch rogue one
a Star Wars story so we wanted to do a
review of it we're going to do something
special tonight because it's [ __ ]
Road one we're going to be going over to
andrews because he's right down the
street from the theater we're going to
and we're going to do a live stream
rogue one a spoiler review our movie
starts at seven o'clock we'll probably
get to his place around 10 to 1030
somewhere there we're gonna go live
right away everything's already set up
ready for us to go for so we'll be live
on you now at the greg alba it will live
stream directly to youtube so if you
don't have a you now account no need to
worry oh it's just getting one anyway
anywho yeah and people can chime in and
whatever give their thoughts and
opinions if you ask us questions make
sure that it's rogue one related okay a
lot of times you guys will probably want
to ask questions about other things
which is cool and all but for this
specific live stream we want to keep
every question that we actually answer
the rogue one related so it's mainly
going to be for people who saw it or if
you have thoughts and if you haven't
seen it there will be spoilers so keep a
lookout for that will be doing that a
live stream and about I don't know four
hours a little less than that keep a
lookout